What makes predictive modeling difficult? We have
millions of patients we want to analyze their
diagnosis information, medication information, and
so on. All this data combined together, create a
big challenge. The second challenge in predictive
modeling is, there's so many models to be built.
Predictive modeling is not a single algorithm,
it's a sequence of computational tasks.
We've introduced predictive modeling pipeline
in more details in the previous lecture.
The truth is, every step in this
pipeline has many different options.
All of those combined give us many
pipelines to be evaluated and compared.
You might be wondering why do we need different
algorithms for one problem. Are five different
algorithms really necessary? Can't we just
decide which algorithm works best and use
that for every problem? We did look at when you
should and shouldn't use each of these algorithms,
whether there is limited data, performance
thresholds, or compute power limitations.
This isn't one size fits all. There's no
free lunch theorem works for every problem.
We know some of the tendencies
and strengths of each algorithm.
We can use that to narrow down the algorithms
that we're considering for a given problem.
But what are the questions that we need to be
asking? When do we not to use certain algorithms?
Generally, these questions
fall under two broad categories. Accuracy and
latency. We'll start with latency. We talked
about how logistic regression is really fast
to train, while SVM are quite slow. So, if you
have limited compute power or limited time, then
you'll want to lean toward logistic regression.
The next question is, how long? Maybe, if you have
a lot of real time data coming in that you need to
make really fast, real time predictions on, then
you might want to consider logistic regression.
Now, moving over to accuracy. What does
our data look like? Is it short and fat?
Is it long and skinny? For instance, if
it's short and fat, in other words, it has
a lot of features but very few rows, we talked
about how SVM does quite well in this space.
The next question is just how complex is this
dataset? Are there clear connections that should
be easy to pick up on? If so, then we should
start thinking about prioritizing time to train
or predict. However, if the relationships are
really complex, then we'll probably start thinking
about something like multilayer perceptrons, or
SVM, where they take a little longer to train,
but they're much better at picking up
on these really complex relationships.
Lastly, how messy is our data? If there are a lot
of outliers, then SVM is probably a good choice,
while logistic regression probably is not. Using
the tendencies and strengths of the algorithms,
we can narrow down the algorithms considered
for a given problem. But, the bottom line is,
sometimes we just don't know which algorithm
will perform best. So, we just need to test
a few and see which actually does perform
best on the data that we have. Generally,
you'll start with maybe six or seven algorithms to
consider, you'll narrow it down to three or four
with these questions, and then you'll just test
those three or four with various hyper parameter
settings to try to find the best model for the
data and problem that you have in front of you.
We've learned about some of the
strengths and weaknesses of each.
Let’s compare these 5 algorithms across 6 key
dimensions, before we run an actual comparison
of each model. The 6 dimensions that will compare
across these algorithms are problem type, time to
train, time to make predictions, interpretability,
performance and performance with limited data.
This table will help you to
decide when to use each of these
algorithms.
For problem type, logistic regression and
SVM can only be used in classification.
In other words, they can only be used for
problems with a categorical target variable.
Multilayer perceptron, random forest, and boosted
trees can be used for both classification and
regression. In other words, they can be used for
both categorical and continuous target variables.
Training speed. This is particularly important.
If you have a lot of data or
you have compute restrictions.
In those cases, training speed can be prohibited.
Random forest is relatively fast. And the other
three are really quite slow, with SVM probably
being the slowest. This also will depend on the
hyperparameter settings for each algorithm.
For prediction speed, boosted trees and
logistic regression is considered quite fast.
Again, recall that boosted trees
are trained in a parallel manner,
so it's quite fast. The other 3 algorthms,
although quite fast, but is behind logistic
regression and boosted trees.
For interpretability, the reality is that none
of these models are particularly interpretable.
Logistic regression is probably the most
interpretable by offering some tools to understand
what's going on under the hood. Of the other
4 algorithms, boosted trees and random forest
is slightly better than multilayer perceptron
and SVM, because at least they offer that how
different features are contributing to your model.
Performance is a big one for obvious reasons.
Boosted trees is slow to train and it's not
interpretable, but it's highly flexible and
typically performs very well on almost any
problem. Multilayer perceptron also perform
well on most problems, but it's a step behind
boosted trees. Random forest and SVM are then
a step behind those two and logistic regression
comes in last on performance. Again, this is
subject to things like the size of the data,
the shape of the data, and how messy your data is.
Now in the big data era, it may seem odd to have
a column here for performance on limited data.
But, you might surprise that a lot of the
industries deal with small set of data,
but with a lot of features. SVM is
the one that really excels here.
Especially when you have a lot of features, but
not a lot of examples. Logistic regression also
does quite well with limited data. The one that
is severely disadvantaged with limited data,
is multilayer perceptron. Now that
we've compared all these algorithms,
let’s compare them all based on performance
on the validation set in the next lecture.